- So big news related to a
possible criminal investigation
of the Trump organization.
New York Attorney General
Letitia James announces
that the Attorney General's
office is teaming up
with the Manhattan
District Attorney's office,
run by Cy Vance, to combine efforts,
and that the Attorney
General's investigation
is no longer just civil, but
is also criminal in nature.
Now, the Manhattan
District Attorney's office
was already engaged in a
criminal investigation.
You might recall that the
grand jury subpoena went up
to the Supreme Court
twice where Trump lost
and the District Attorneys won,
and they should have access
to all of those records.
But what is particularly interesting
is that the New York
Attorney General's office
is now teaming up with the Manhattan DA.
That basically doesn't happen.
That might mean that this investigation
is getting a supercharge,
or it just might mean
that the Attorney General's
office wants some of the credit.
The New York AG tends to
announce more investigations
than it actually prosecutes,
so we'll see whether
we see anyone in court.